[Musique]
à la une cédric joue bien dans après une
marche blanche commémoratives se
dérouler cet après-midi en souvenir de
ce leader de 42 ans est mort à la suite
de son arrestation policière le 3
janvier 2020 ses proches demandent
toujours la suspension des agents
impliqués dans la sphère cela ressemble
fort à un couac dans la stratégie
sanitaire du gouvernement emmanuel
macron semble trouver la campagne
vaccinale je ne cite pas à la hauteur ni
du moment ni des français des propos
tenus dans le jdd est la veille de la
rentrée scolaire demain de nombreux
parents et professeurs sont sains
question des réseaux sociaux des
collectifs et scientifique ont
interpellé le ministre de l'éducation
et puis l'insécurité au au sel toujours
au coeur de l'actualité deux soldats
français dont une femme ont été tués
samedi dans le nord-est du mali lors
d'une attaque à l'engin explosif
improvisé à un troisième a été blessé
mais ses jours ne sont pas dans
j'ai ce qui porte à cinq le nombre de
militaires tricolores qui ont trouvé la
mort cette semaine dans la région de
façon similaire au total 55 hommes ont
péri pendant leur mission au sahel
depuis 2013
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france une marche
blanche à la mémoire des victimes via
s'est déroulée dans le calme cet après
midi à paris elle est partie de la place
de leurs goûts et les proches d'eric
joviado demande la suspension des
policiers mis en cause dans sa mort le
chauffeur livreur est décédé le 3
janvier 2020 la suite d'un contrôle
policier au cours duquel il a été plaqué
au sol on revient sur cette marche avec
notre reporter nadège abderrazak une
marche qui a débuté en début d'après
midi depuis la place de l'uruguay pour
se terminer trois heures plus tard quai
branly à deux pas de la tour eiffel 1
c'est là que s'est déroulée
l'interpellation de cédric joue via il y
a un an jour pour jour
il a fait l'objet et d'une clé
d'étranglement et qui a fracturé son
larynx et provoquer son malaise
transporté à l'hôpital il décédera deux
jours plus tard à leur famille proches
et amis ont décidé d'organiser cette
marche blanche
un an plus tard pour rendre hommage à la
victime et puis à réclamer justice il
demande de nouveau la suspension des
quatre policiers mis en cause dans cette
affaire
pour moi aujourd'hui après réflexion
c'est un guet-apens
il a été étranglé étranglé avec une
fracture du larynx
on n'y a pas laissé de chance de survie
on l'a laissé sur le trottoir pendant
plus de trois minutes sans rupture de
pelotage vantera les tremblements et
aujourd'hui la justice est elle suit son
cours elle travaille bien mais par
contre ce qui paraît y penser le
ministère de
ministère de la police qui fait rien il
veut pas les mettre à pied et ça ça nous
révolte c'est une révolte parce que ça
fait un an
ils sont toujours en exergue un exercice
ils font rien et il se passe ce qui se
passe il c'est parce qu'aujourd'hui
c'est une injustice
à partir du moment où quelqu'un bat à
des gestes violents et n'arrivent pas à
s'arrêter et 30 quelqu'un jusqu'à casser
fracturé son larynx pour moi bah ouais
c'est un crime c'est un acte de violence
et et
et de meurtre pour moi pour moi je le
dis dans ce qui fut comme un meurtre on
fait confiance à la justice on attend ça
prendra son cours tout doucement on est
on en est conscient mais au niveau du
gouvernement et ce qui concerne en fait
l'implication et au moins prouvé une ce
qu'ils puissent avoir une sanction et
qu'on ait compris on invoque
gouvernement parce que pour le moment il
y ait aucune réaction de leur part en
fait
et parmi les manifestants figurent
plusieurs personnalités politiques
eric coquerel député de la france en
soumises esther benbassa a débuté europe
ecologie les verts
plusieurs militants associatifs et
également des familles de victimes à ça
traoré a fait le déplacement ainsi que
amal bencsik cofondatrice du collectif
urgence
notre police assassines c'est important
parce qu'on sait ô combien c'est
difficile à chaque fois de se remémorer
ces instants douloureux la vie nos
proches s'est arrêtée en tant que
famille on doit se battre deux fois plus
pour essayer d'obtenir la justice
d'obtenir la mise en examen d'obtenir la
suspension des policiers qui sont mis en
cause
cédric julia c'est pratiquement la même
affaire que floyd aux etats-unis
c'est-à-dire quelqu'un qui
est assassiné par la police qui dit j'ai
tout fait groleau rico et qu'on laisse
pour les secourir
or constatez vous même ça n'a pas fait
autant de bruit qu'ça en france vous
êtes promenés à des seuls médias disent
présent je veux dire sous alors que
c'est ça fait un an jour pour jour qu'a
eu lieu cette affaire est alors que
trois des quatre policiers mis en cause
ont été mises en examen cet été pour
homicide involontaire
aucun d'entre eux n'a été suspendus ou
démis de ses fonctions et c'est ce que
demande la famille depuis plusieurs mois
la famille qui envisage d'ailleurs de
nouveaux domaines
à l'avenir pour se faire entendre et
nous rejoignons doria joue via la veuve
de cédric joue via bonsoir à vous merci
d'être avec nous ce soir sur rtl france
alors on l'a vu une marche aujourd'hui
que s'est déroulé dans le calme avec de
nombreux collectifs qui ont rejoint
cette marche avec vous aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que vous retenez signalement
de cette journée je retiens que est
indifférent à cette injustice et à nos
souffrances en fin de compte au niveau
de la population
on a vu que les gens se sentaient
concernés et qu'il était là pour nous
soutenir et on compte bien sûr et on a
bien besoin d'eux et et nous va écouter
on sait pas la manche on ne monte pas ce
qu'on demande c'est c'est tout à fait
légitime moment parce que les quatre
policiers qui sont directement impliqués
dans la mort de mon époux soient déjà
dans un premier temps suspendu de leurs
fonctions car il s'en indigne de rester
dans la police étant donné qu'ils ont
ils ont tué un père de un père de
famille et ils ont des comptes à rendre
comme n'importe quel citoyen et il
représente pas du tout aujourd'hui la
loi ou cette corporation policière qui s
en serait fait pourrir protéger et des
îles ont pas leur place dans la police
et on peut pas on peut pas accepter
qu'il soit toujours en fonction c'est
pas possible donc à chaque fois qu'on
aura l'opportunité de de réclamer ce
droitier de justice dans le fera sans
cesse trois de ses policiers mis en
cause ont été mises en examen est ce que
selon vous c'est le signe que l'on tête
avance finalement à wil enquête ya rien
à dire en face à ça mais le temps que ça
mes mails enquête lui avance il ya des
expertises de retours d'expertisés assez
régulièrement
on a pu grâce aux vidéos grâce aux
témoignages expertises
on a pu prouver que ces quatre policiers
directement appliquée dans dans la mort
de cédric et maintenant ce qu'on attend
c'est une réponse du gouvernement qui
doit reconnaître
voilà qui va lui qui a une grosse
terrible que ça affligeant et où et pour
toutes les autres familles des victimes
et qu'on peut pas continuer comme ça
enfin aujourd'hui ils ont des comptes à
rendre et il faut faire en sorte que
tout ça on va pas système les familles
sont parties stéphane automatiquement
défilé dans les rues pour réclamer
justice
on va faire en sorte qu'une injustice
qu'ils soient commises et là je crois
qu'on commencera mialanes est ce que
vous vous êtes confiante parce que l'un
de vos avocats maître arié alimi a
déclaré aujourd'hui chez nos confrères
de france info que systématiquement dans
les dossiers de violences policières il
ya une volonté de protéger les
fonctionnaires de police auteur des
faits ce que vous êtes d'accord avec lui
ah oui complètement c'est un put on l'a
vu à n'acheter que trop duré et
systématiquement quand on se renseigne
autour de nous auprès des familles des
victimes
quand il ya un procès c'est
systématiquement un non lieu est encore
une fois même mamie d'instruction par
constat devenir presque un luxe et on
peut pas on peut pas accepter on peut
pas tolérer donc on invite un maximum de
personnes à se joindre
voilà acheter de pause et à faire en
sorte que les policiers ne soient pas
amenés à tuer des d un justement
gratuitement des citoyens qui sont eux
qui n'ont qu'à vivre en cette chambre
on se souvient on se souvient qu'à
l'époque le ministre de l'intérieur en
poste christophe castaner vous avez reçu
il vous avait donné des garanties à
l'époque j'ai tellement il nous avait
promis qu'une fois que j'aurai des faits
avérés en sachant qu il y aurait
forcément une pension d'état policier
cela n'a pas été fait et il avait
également
il avait également évoqué le fait qu'il
avait l'intention de mettre un terme à
la clé entre le mans et aux plaquages
ventrale de ce que je sais c'est
toujours en face les cette pratique est
toujours d'actualité malheureusement on
entendu tout à l'heure eric coquerel
faire le lien avec la sphère georgia
floyd c'était le cas aussi de danser
traoré qui participait d'ailleurs à
cette marche qui avait aussi fait le
lien vous aussi vous le faites ce lien
vous vous ne craignez pas qu'on vous le
reproche parce que ça a été souvent le
cas dans dans le cas de la sphère adama
traoré non forcément on sait le lien
c'est tout à fait logique et je leur
offre pour nous le reprocherait en fait
on n'est plus aujourd'hui en mesure de
reprocher pas mal de choses et je vois
pas ce qu'on va nous reprocher ou à
notre patience le dignité notre appel à
la paix qu'est ce qu'on va nous
reprocher exactement de prendre notre
mal en patience c'est soit aujourd'hui
le combat il va se poursuivre dans la
rue notamment aux côtés de du collectif
stop la sécurité globale
ah oui oui ça c'est on est on est lié on
il y est on est de tout coeur avec eux
et on on pense que notre place est il
d'ailleurs la place de tous les citoyens
qui souhaitent préserver leurs droits et
leurs libertés
on leur donne tous rendez vous aux
différentes manifestations qui va y
avoir successivement pour en janvier
pour s'opposer à toutes ces lois
liberticides et et à ce futur état
police qui risquent d'émerger
tôt ou tard en fait et qui est déjà là
même j'ai envie de vous dire mais vous
savez aussi que ces manifestations
contre la loi sécurité globale en marge
de ces manifestations il ya aussi eu des
heurts avec
les forces de police par rapport à cela
quel est votre sentiment
c'est écoeurant moi personnellement avec
mes enfants n'a participé à la
manifestation
on s'est retrouvé presque presque
asphyxié en fin de compte
et alors qu'on n'avait rien fait de mal
on est et on était là à marcher comme
tout le monde et subitement on a été
chargée de bons matchs imogène et ça je
crois que c'est pour une idée de de ne
plus venir manifester et vous faut tenir
le coup et essayer de faire une chose
pacifiquement possible et par rapport à
ça par rapport à ces manifestations qui
étaient déjà vers à qui vous en voulez
le plus peut-être pas aux forces de
l'ordre qui exécute aussi des ordres oui
mais a pris le contrôle aux forces de
l'ordre
ça reste des caresses des citoyens avant
tout et réalisons ce qu'on appelle le
libre arbitre et enfin je vais dire si
demain on leur demande de ballet de
balancer les manifestants dans la selle
et qu'on leur dit derrière et clark
unités ces deux morts le mot du jour
est ce qu'ils vont nous balancer aussi
dans la sienne on va pas en arriver
avant sachant que c'est un vieux mais là
avant nous on est là pour dire stop non
et on a beaucoup d'espoir parce qu'on
estime que dans ces moments là c'est des
moments de réflexion de remise en
question et c'est de là qu'ils émergent
injustement des réformes des nouvelles
idées pour essayer d'améliorer les
choses là aujourd'hui
enfin je veux bien le but c'est pas sans
cesse de réclamer la justice c'est de
faire en sorte que ces gens
s'investissent n'ait pas lieu faut
prendre le problème à l'envers parce que
sinon il faut prendre le problème à sa
racine est la racine c'est que c'est
qu'aujourd'hui les ceux qui dirigent la
police les donneurs c'est des gens
malveillants mal à fonctionner 8 syndic
et on peut pas les laisser donné des
gens comme ça tout va qui met en péril
la vie de citoyens qui viennent
légitimement contestée
loi ou une réforme ou je ne sais pas
encore merci beaucoup à vous doria
souvient vous êtes donc la veuve de
cédric joue via merci pour avoir réagi
sur rtl france à l'issue de cette marche
commémorative en hommage à votre mari la
campagne vaccinale a commencé en france
mais elle est jugée trop lente par
rapport à ses voisins européens
à titre de comparaison moins de 500
personnes ont été vaccinées dans
l'hexagone contre 1 million en grande
bretagne est presque 150 milles en
allemagne une lenteur qui agace emmanuel
macron selon le journal du dimanche le
président a confié à ses proches qu'il
souhaitait que la campagne s'accélère
nous sommes sur un rythme de promenade
en famille et ce n'est à la hauteur ni
du moment ni des français
moi je fais la guerre le matin le midi
le soir et la nuit
et j'attends de tous le même engagement
or là ça ne va pas ça doit changer vite
et fort et ça va changer vite et fort
et demain c'est le jour de la rentrée
des classes les parents et les
professeurs ne cachent pas leur
inquiétude en cause cette étude concorde
l'institut pasteur selon laquelle les
risques de transmission du virus sont
plus importants à la crèche en
maternelle au collège et au lycée qu'à
l'école primaire ou à l'université
d'ailleurs cette semaine à des
scientifiques et des collectifs de
parents d'élèves ont interpellé le
ministre de l'éducation jean michel
blanc car ils ont demandé un report de
la rentrée comme c'est le cas dans
d'autres pays européens
et selon nicolas glières enseignants et
membres des stylos rouges il est
nécessaire d'agir et de réduire les
effectifs à l'instar de nos voisins
européens
on a un ministre qui est totalement
sourd à tous nos appels
depuis le mois de juin nous demandons à
ce que le les écoles et collèges des
lycées ce façon 2000 groupe pour éviter
justement cette contagion pour éviter la
deuxième vague n'avons jamais entendu
résultat on est dedans
la troisième vague et là elle arrive en
fait c'est bien la pologne même le
prolongement de la deuxième vague
puisque rien n'a été fait de sérieux en
france on est le seul pays quasiment en
europe 1 continuer à avoir les écoles
ouvertes à 35 40 par classe sans aucune
distanciation sociale
des écoles qui pourrait fermer au
royaume uni c'est ce qu'a évoqué boris
johnson dans un entretien à la bbc
c'est aussi ce que réclament plusieurs
syndicats d'enseignants britanniques il
se peut que nous devions faire des
choses difficiles dans les prochaines
semaines a déclaré avery johnson qui a
également reconnu l'impact du nouveau
virus
le royaume uni qui reste l'un des pays
les plus en deuil et en europe avec plus
de 75 mille victimes ces dernières 24
heures près de cinquante cinq mille
personnes supplémentaires ont été
testées positives
et puis en italie le gouvernement
envisage de rendre la vaccination contre
le coc vide 19 obligatoire un passage en
force au cas où nous trop d'italiens se
montre très méfiant vis-à-vis du vaccin
les précisions avec walid ben ali à
l'opposé d'une boîte de pandore l'espoir
désormais condensé dans une petite fiole
les résidents âgés d'une maison de son
art homme dont la tante de recevoir un
vaccin si longtemps désirée je suis un
peu nerveux mais une fois que vous avez
fait le vaccin
vous vous sentez libre et les choses
semblent positifs pour la ville comme un
soulagement également pour gerardo
pensionnaires de cette structure depuis
le 4 mars 2020 de l'autre côté des alpes
le troisième âge durement touchés selon
l'institut supérieur de la santé
l'âge moyen des personnes décédées et
testée positive au qu'ovide 19 au pic de
l'épidémie
dépassés les 79 ans le gouvernement
transalpin satisfait aujourd'hui de
pouvoir présenter un remède miracle
il s'agit clairement du premier pas sur
un chemin qui n'est pas cours un chemin
qui nécessite encore de nombreuses
semaines de travail acharné pour que le
vaccin soit administrée à un grand
nombre de personnes
nous devrons encore résisté pendant les
semaines à venir et nous battre en
utilisant les instruments que nous avons
obtenu une campagne de vaccination qui a
débuté le 27 décembre dernier
avec une primauté donnée à cinq médecins
et infirmières d'un hôpital romain
spécialisé dans les maladies
infectieuses personnels de santé
personnes âgées puis viendront les
enseignants policiers et gardiens de
prison le vaccin
érigé au rang de devoir national par le
pouvoir
marchena a fait on l'achète pas de se
faire vacciner est un choix de
responsabilité un devoir
d'autant plus pour ceux qui travaillent
au contact des malades et des personnes
les plus fragiles face à une maladie
contagieuse qui provoque tant de décès
il est nécessaire de protéger sa propre
santé et il est de son devoir de
protéger celle des autres membres de la
famille amis et collègues collègues
si dans les prochains mois la campagne
ne devait pas atteindre les deux tiers
de la population alors nous devrions
prendre des mesures parmi celles ci il y
aura l'obligation mais la question ne se
pose pas aujourd'hui
le terme d'obligation qui fait grincer
des dents du côté de l'opposition
je suis pour l'éducation mais je suis
contre l'obligation
il est juste que les médecins expliquent
informe mais je n'aime pas les
contraintes
je suis convaincu que la seule façon de
faire une campagne sérieuse et
d'informer correctement les gens sans
hystérie ni parade d'aucune sorte
le gouvernement italien a passé commande
auprès de six laboratoire avec la
possibilité de pouvoir vacciner jusqu'à
13 millions de personnes
dès le 1er avril
[Applaudissements]
en centrafrique maintenant des rebelles
armés ont pris le contrôle aujourd'hui
de bangassou une ville située à 750 km à
l'est de la capitale bangui selon le
chef du bureau régional de la mission de
l'onu en centrafrique les rebelles
contrôlent la ville
ils sont partout cette attaque a lieu à
la veille des résultats partiels de
l'élection présidentielle du 27 décembre
des résultats attendus donc demain et
puis au mali deux soldats français de
l'opération barkan ont été tués hier une
attaque terroriste qui survient cinq
jours après le décès de trois autres
militaires français dans ce pays
d'afrique de l'ouest
au total 55 morts pendant leur mission
au fel depuis 2013 les précisions avec
hélas mais jet le sergent yvonne huisne
33 ans est la première femme de l'armée
française tués au sahel depuis 2013
le brigadier loïc risser et est lui âgé
d'à peine 24 ans tous deux engagés dans
un régiment spécialisé dans le
renseignement
le véhicule blindé de ces deux
militaires a sauté ce samedi sous un
engin explosif artisanal
c'était lors d'une mission de
reconnaissance de l'opération barkan
dans la région de ménaka au mali
un troisième soldat français a également
été blessé lors de cette attaque mais
ses jours ne sont pas en danger
la france a perdu deux de ses enfants
je rends hommage à la force de
l'engagement du sergent even usines et
du brigadier loïc risser du 2e régiment
de hussards de haguenau il incarne
l'honneur et la bravoure des hussards de
chamboux rang mes pensées vont à leurs
familles
la motivation la pugnacité et
l'abnégation des militaires français
demeurent intactes de face aux groupes
terroristes filière de déchets d'al
qaïda qui s'aiment terreur est ko au
mali et au sahel dans un communiqué de
l'elysée le président français salue
également la mémoire des deux soldats
morts dans leur mission
emmanuel macron qui réaffirme que paris
continuera coûte que coûte à se battre
contre le terrorisme au sahel
le président de la république réaffirme
la détermination de la france dans son
combat contre le terrorisme
il salue le courage de nos soldats et
les assure de sa confiance et de son
soutien face à cette nouvelle épreuve
une nouvelle épreuve douloureuse pour la
france en à peine une semaine
lundi dernier trois soldats de l'armée
français sont tombés dans les mêmes
circonstances au mali le brigadier-chef
tannerie maury et les chasseur de 1ère
classe d'orient issac aniane et quand
empocher une attaque à la bombe
artisanale revendiquer ce samedi par la
branche d'al qaïda au sahel
ces soldats français mené leur toute
première mission depuis à peine deux
mois dans la zone des trois frontières
région où se rencontrent le mali le
burkina faso et le niger en janvier
dernier à l'issue du sommet de pau la
france a engagé six cents soldats
supplémentaires au sahel portant ses
effectifs environ 5000 101 ans après ce
renforcement militaire paris examine en
ce moment l'évolution de cet engagement
la france pourrait amorcer un début de
retrait de ses troupes dans la zone des
trois frontières
pour l'instant aucun calendrier officiel
n'a été arrêté malgré la série noire ces
derniers jours qu'ils touchent
l'opération barkan pour pirlo jong
senior vice président de l'institut
tennis et président de l'association
europe mauritanie le dispositif barkan
ne devrait pas se retirer à de la région
sahélienne
on les coupe pour réaménager on peut
repenser dispositif
on peut éventuellement inciter la minus
maroc avec des douze ou treize mille
hommes à s'engager davantage on peut
également comment dire que pousser nos
poussées no comment dire à nos
partenaires sahéliens à s'engager
davantage la force conjointe aujourd'hui
elle elle est opérationnelle qu'en
partie on voit bien ça fait deux ans
qu'on attend on attend du comment dire
une une montée en puissance qui n'avait
toujours pas donc on voit qu'il ya
différentes modalités on peut
s'interroger aujourd'hui quand tu
continues du monde du nombre de morts
qui a eu depuis une semaine les cinq
derniers mort si vous voulez on peut
s'interroger sur un dispositif alors
encore une fois je pense pas qu'il faut
s'interroger faille s'interroger sur un
départ c'est pas ça veut dire mais à
rien ménagement une nouvelle
organisation nouvelle manière de voir
les choses fait rentrer plus d'européens
les européens font sont fabuleusement
absent de cette opération alors bien sûr
il ya quelques moyens la force la cobac
mais ça reste quand même des
déclarations politiques et pour
l'instant c'est la france qui assume
seule le fardeau
c'était il ya un an le général iranien
soleymani a été tué par une frappe de
drone américain en irak à bagdad
une cérémonie d'hommage plusieurs
milliers de personnes se sont
rassemblées en l'honneur du chef
militaire mais aussi des manifestations
contre la présence américaine dans le
pays
tehran également à commémorer le premier
anniversaire de la mort du haut gradé
déjà au lendemain du décès du général
des foules immenses avaient déferlé
partout en iran un assassinat ciblé qui
avait fait craindre un affrontement
direct entre l'iran et les états unis on
voit cela avec tériade lazaristes sa
mort avait exacerbé les tensions entre
états unis et iran la république
islamique en hommage au général qasem
soleimani assassiné le 3 janvier 2020
son convoi avait été la cible d'un drone
américain près de l'aéroport de bagdad
l'iran avait riposté en ciblant des
bases américaines en irak
aujourd'hui encore sa disparition
suscite un sentiment de vengeance de la
part du chef de l'autorité judiciaire
iranienne
ne pensez pas que quelqu'un comme le
président des états unis qui apparaît
comme un assassin ou qui a ordonné un
assassinat peut s'en tirer et se sentir
protégés de la loi et de la justice et
se sentir en sécurité
jamais ceux qui ont joué un rôle dans ce
meurtre ne seront nulle part en sécurité
sur cette terre déjà considéré comme une
légende de son vivant
le chef de la force al qods l'unité
d'élite des gardiens de la révolution
islamique
et depuis son décès élevés au rang de
martyrs par tout un peuple
apprécié pour son calme et sa proximité
avec ses soldats kouassem soleymani a
oeuvré pour renforcer l'influencé
iranienne dans la région notamment en
irak
ce dimanche c'est d'ailleurs dans la
capitale irakienne que les tensions
américano iranienne
risquer de se faire ressentir
l'ambassade américaine à bagdad
déjà ciblé après la mort du général
craignaient de nouvelles attaques
pas plus tard qu'il ya deux semaines une
salve de roquettes a explosé près du
bâtiment sans avoir été revendiqué
l'ambassade qui a également annoncé
avoir fourni 30 véhicules blindés à
l'armée irakienne
pour se prémunir d'éventuelles
représailles
et pour gérer un vestiaire analyste
géopolitique cette attaque elle touche
qui a touché l'iran et l'irak n'a pas
ressoudé les deux états pour autant
écouter il y avait des tensions
historiques et politiques entre l'iran
perse et l'irak arabe
il ya eu huit ans de guerre ils ont pas
de 1980 à 1988 il y à cette différence
entre arabes et perses à on n'a pas la
même langue on n'a pas la même histoire
donc vous avez ces différents cela qui
ne demande qu'à resurgir
certes il y a trente cinq mille
miliciens irakien payé par téhéran pour
renforcer si vous voulez la présence
militaro politique de l'iran en irak
il y a huit consulat iranien en irak qui
sont dirigés par des gardiens de la
révolution iraniens donc vous voyez il
ya un dispositif mais au fond le pays
n'a pas ce sentiment d' allianz et c'est
la fin de ce champ d'al merci à vous de
l'avoir suivi on va se retrouver en
direct dans 30 minutes à rester avec
nous sur arte france
[Musique]
des organes d'un flux ans de propagande
et de propagande mensongère
richard good est montreuil pour le
château
[Musique]
alors non mais vous êtes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
c'est un coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent la
haine en soi vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche extrême
musée tous les témoins de notre époque
sont dans la grande interwiew certains
disent que nous ne sommes pas une chaîne
française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même